und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend eine tragende säule des
grundgesetzes ist ins gerede gekommen
artikel 3 der gleichheits artikel fußt
auf dem fundament unserer verfassung dem
ersten satz die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar antwort auf das
menschenverachtende naziregime artikel 3
absatz 3 macht das dann konkret niemand
darf wegen seines geschlechtes seiner
abstammung seiner rasse seiner sprache
herkunft oder anderen solchen gründen
benachteiligt oder bevorzugt werden und
da steht tatsächlich das wort rasse als
bahn gegen den völkermorden den
rassenwahn der nazis ein ehrenwertes
motiv aber ein schwieriges wort
heute sagt die wissenschaft und heute
wissen wir dass von menschenrassen keine
rede sein kann es gibt keine
fundamentalen unterschiede zwischen
menschen verschiedener herkunft oder
hautfarbe
das wort ist ein kampfbegriff dazu
geschaffen vermeintlich schwächere zu
unterdrücken
und das ist ja nicht vorbei das
geschieht heute noch und nun ist auch
wegen black lies meter eine debatte groß
geworden ob dieses wort im grundgesetz
bleiben darf rasse trotzen nobler ab
sich sozusagen wegen seiner herkunft
frank buchwald berichtet demonstrationen
heute überall in deutschland auch in
berlin
sie köpfen ein buntes band der
solidarität vom brandenburger tor bis
nach neukölln wollen zeichen setzen auch
gegen rassismus viel zustimmung kommt
aus der politik die grünen schlagen
deshalb vor ob das grundgesetz zu ändern
wenn wir der meinung sind es gibt keine
rassen und jeder sollte der meinung sein
dann sollten wir das grundgesetz adäquat
formulieren und stattdessen sagen es
sollte keine niemand sollte wegen
rassistischer zuschreibung diskriminiert
werden dann haben wir eine klare kante
gegen rassismus ohne uns im rasse
begriff unglaubwürdig zu machen
es geht um artikel 3 des grundgesetzes
berliner politiker haben ihn immer vor
augen eingraviert in einer glaswand
mitten im regierungsviertel
niemand darf diskriminiert werden klar
der begriff rasse im gesetzestext aber
stört viele auch die justizministerin
das grundgesetz ist immer eine abbildung
unserer werteordnung und es ist der
kampf gegen rassistische diskriminierung
und dieser begriff kann anders
verstanden werden und er wird ja auch
anders genutzten deswegen sollten wir
aufgerufen sein dass jetzt auch
entsprechend zu verändern
einige in der union sehen das kritisch
sie argumentieren das grundgesetz so wie
es ist setze ohnehin schon starke
zeichen gegen rassismus
deshalb halte ich es für eine absolute
schein und symbol debatte wenn wir jetzt
versuchen würden sprach polizeilich
unsere verfassung zu überarbeiten
es ist ein klarer absoluter
diskriminierungsschutz und es sollte
nicht verbessert werden
die mütter und väter des grundgesetzes
die den text vor 70 jahren entwarfen
wollten ein signal gegen rassismus
setzen eine lehre aus dem rassenwahn der
nationalsozialisten
der mono kost endete nach den
erfahrungen der nazizeit und diesem
schlimmsten rassismus denen es in der
geschichte überhaupt je gegeben hat
wollen sie das ausdrücklich ausschließen
und das entsprach auch dem zeitgeist
gesagt das völkerrecht sah das zu der
zeit schon vor und sieht es auch heute
noch vor und das unionsrecht auch aber
wenn man das streicht es steht ja auch
abstammung man darf auch nicht wegen der
abstammung diskriminiert werden das
reicht die justizministerin unterstützt
die änderung und die kanzlerin zeigt
sich offen für eine debatte
das thema dürfte berlin deshalb wohl
noch eine weile beschäftigen
übermorgen am dienstag soll die
bekämpfung der korona pandemie in eine
neue phase treten die lang erwartete
corona app ist dann endlich
einsatzbereit
sie soll den überblick über das paar
demi geschehen so sehr verbessern dass
vielmehr lockerungen möglich werden
vorausgesetzt die leute trauen der sache
und laden diese app herunter die sende
dann mit einer besonderen bluetooth
funktechnik dauernd wechselnde
identifikations codes aus und speichert
die aber nur in deinem telefon
gleichzeitig horcht die app auf
entsprechende signale von handys anderer
leute in der nähe wenn solch reinkommen
tauschen die geräte diese codes aus nur
die codes keine namen keine telefon noch
mal nichts womit man jemanden
identifizieren kann
so entsteht eine zweite liste mit den
codes von geräten die man getroffen hat
und nur wenn ein nutzer positiv getestet
wurde
dann kann der das muss er nicht seiner
app erlauben die liste der eigenen codes
auf einen zentralen server hochzuladen
die zweite liste mit den codes der
betroffenen personen bleibt auf deinem
handy ganz privat und erst dann verteilt
der server die codes der infizierten
person an sämtliche smartphones mit der
app im ganzen land die prüfen dann ganz
diskret jedes für sich ob sie diesen
infizierten code mal begegnet sind und
wenn ja dann erfährt der besitzer ich
war irgendwann mal in der nähe irgend
einer infizierten person nur er erfährt
dass niemand sonst und darf jetzt jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden was er oder
sie macht die sache ignorieren oder zum
beispiel einen test
so soll das gehen ein system das nur
funktioniert wenn millionen menschen ihm
vertrauen ist wenn ricken berichtet so
sieht sie aus die deutsche corona app
der programmcode also die zeilen die
eine app ausmachen sind frei im netz
einsehbar
matthias ordnung hat sich diesen
sourcecode heruntergeladen und die app
gestartet so deutlich wie zum beispiel
die eingabe funktioniert wenn der nutzer
positiv auf kurve 19 getestet wurde
wenn ich jetzt beim arzt gewesen bin
bekomme ich einen sogenannten code oder
ein qr-code wo ich quasi diese diesen
abscannen kann und dann weiß die app
ganz genau okay ich bin jetzt infiziert
wurde positiv getestet
nur so zum spaß kann also niemand einen
echten corona alarm an den server
schicken die app ermittelt permanent ein
infektionsrisiko und zeigt das ergebnis
in farben an springt die anzeige auf rot
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit einer
infektion gegeben das sagt natürlich
noch nichts über eine wirkliche
erkrankung aus der betroffene weiß für
den zeitpunkt nicht ob er erkrankt ist
ja oder nein dabei weiß dass er sich
einem gewissen risiko gefunden hat was
mache ich damit klassischerweise wenn
mal eine woche in quarantäne gehen ja
dann wird natürlich die frage geklärt
kann ich mich der krankschreiben das
sind ja selbstverständlich natürlich
musste hier vorher garantieren ganz
genauso er kann auch so einen arzt
aufsuchen und kann sie ab streichen
lassen und kann sich testen lassen und
die entscheidung zum arzt zu gehen oder
das gesundheitsamt zu informieren so
haben es auch google und apple
vorgegeben trifft ausschließlich der
nutzer datenschutz in reinster form
komplette eigenverantwortung die
selbstbestimmung geht hier ein stückchen
weiter
denn ich kann freiwillig entscheiden wie
gehe ich mit der information dass sie
mit einem infizierten potenziell in
kontakt gewesen bin und hier ist es
natürlich die frage wie weit ist der
bürger ihr verantwortungsvoll
insbesondere auch gegenüber dritten
seinen mitmenschen und auch der älteren
bevölkerung und beachtet diese vorgaben
einige gesundheitsämter hatten daher
zuletzt gefordert dass die app nicht nur
ihren benutzer informiert sondern auch
beim amt anonym alarm schlägt zwar
schneller als es die behörden über die
listen etwa in cafés könnten das aber
sorgte für kritik
es kann doch nicht sein dass jetzt der
reine verdachtsfall dass sie sich
vielleicht infiziert haben einem
gesundheitsamt gemeldet wird und sie
dann dafür sozusagen an persönlich
angeschrieben werden mit namen und ihnen
dann gesagt wer sie haben jetzt das und
das zu tun also wieviel meldewesen
wollen wir in deutschland dennoch
sozusagen einführen so viel freiheit
kann sich auch verselbständigen was wenn
restaurantbetreiber oder café besitzer
auf die idee kommen app zeigen statt
namen schreiben diskriminierung durch
die hintertür wie in anderen ländern
einige bundesländer fordern ein gesetz
dagegen die bundesregierung setzt auch
hier auf eigenverantwortung die deutsche
corona app ist eben in jeder hinsicht
komplettes neuland
die abgeordnete anke domscheit berg ist
anerkannte experten und eine engagierte
datenschützerin wenn man das so in einem
wort konzentrieren muss sie ist
netzpolitische sprecherin der
linksfraktion im deutschen bundestag
ohne dieser partei anzugehören guten
namen frau domscheit berg werden sie
sich diese web herunterladen und
benutzen also hinsichtlich datenschutz
habe ich im moment keine großen bedenken
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass es eine
überwachung sap und aus diesem grunde
werde ich sie aller voraussicht nach
auch installieren
das können sie tun weil so viel da auf
freiwilligkeit baut man muss kann sie
sich freiwillig runterladen man kann sie
dann freiwillig benutzen
und wenn man mit dieser app eine warnung
bekommt dann kann man freiwillig was tun
zum beispiel freiwillig das
gesundheitsamt anrufen viele viele
punkte wo man sagen kann ich mache nicht
mehr mit wie soll da jemals das große
lagebild entstehen können dass die
virologen brauchen und sicher hoffen ich
glaube es ist der einzige weg wie wir
dazu kommen können denn wenn wir es
nicht freiwillig machen würden wäre die
alternative ja diese app per zwang zu
verpflichten
und das wird in der praxis nicht
funktionieren weil man sie auf ganz
vielen verschiedenen wegen unterlaufen
könnte man kann zum beispiel sein handy
nicht dabei haben
man kann das akku leer haben man kann
einfach bluetooth abschalten oder man
kann die positiv infektion nicht weiter
melden an den zentralen server davon
abgesehen besitzen ja gar nicht alle
menschen ein handy auf dem diese app
überhaupt lauffähig ist
es läuft nur auf apple und auf android
handys das sind ungefähr 80 prozent der
nutzerinnen und nutzer 20 haben so ein
handy gar nicht ich kann aber niemanden
zwingen ein solches handy zu kaufen
schon gar nicht menschen die das geld
vielleicht gar nicht haben
wir können also nur über freiwilligkeit
möglichst viele menschen dazu bringen
dabei nicht zu machen
trotzdem gibt es ja in unserem land
immer auch mal wieder eine pflicht zum
beispiel eine impfpflicht oder die
pflicht bei rot über die ampel zu fahren
die leute schalten ja nicht deshalb
ihren verstand aus und fahren dann
trotzdem wenn es mal kein wenn man die
pflicht unterlaufen kann welches
menschenbild steht dahinter wenn man
sagt man kann die leute nicht mehr auf
fordern in einem rechtsstaat dem recht
zu folgen
also ich halte in diesem fall einfach
gar nichts von zwang weil es in der
praxis nicht funktionieren würde
wir müssen menschen überzeugen und der
beste weg dazu ist eine app auf den
markt zu bringen der menschen vertrauen
können vertrauen ist wirklich das a und
o und das was die bundesregierung machen
muss ist bei jedem handschlag den sie im
bezug auf die app gut zu überlegen
erhöht dass das vertrauen in die kommune
app oder tut es das nicht
da muss ich zum beispiel ganz klar
bemängeln dass es immer noch kein corona
waren app gesetz gibt die
bundesregierung ist der meinung dass
braucht es nicht aber wie schon erklärt
ohne freiwilligkeit funktioniert sie
nicht und wir haben so viel öffentliche
debatte wo auch cdu politiker zb
vordermann soll vor oder nachteile an
die nutzung oder nichtnutzung dieser app
binden das verunsichert menschen das
unterminiert vertrauen und das wird am
ende nicht dazu führen dass mehr
menschen benutzen
was ist denn werden sagen wir ein
kneipenwirt oder eine fluggesellschaft
sagt bei uns kommen nur leute an bord
die diese app dabei haben und erkennbar
nutzen weil wir uns dann besser fühlen
für unsere anderen passagiere oder gäste
der kneipe so ein verhalten muss klar
rechtswidrig seien auch dafür brauchen
das kieler gesetz das muss fest
schreiben dass jede verbindung von vor
und nachteil mit der nutzung oder
nichtnutzung der app nicht nur durch den
staat sondern gerade auch durch dritte
verboten ist und zwar richtig per gesetz
verboten
es muss eine zweckentfremdung verbot
drin sein es muss auch eine harte
befristung in diesem gesetz drin sein
das schafft das notwendige vertrauen
aber nicht indem wir menschen
diskriminieren in abhängigkeit davon
welches handy sie besitzen oder welche
app dort installiert ist
was ist ihr gefühl dafür wenn dieses
ding am dienstag nun quasi auf den markt
kommt und die regierung wir alle darauf
angewiesen sind dass das von millionen
menschen genutzt wird damit es seine
wirkung entfalten kann wird das passiert
das wird die praxis zeigen aber ich
glaube da hat die bundesregierung auch
noch einiges an hausaufgaben zu tun es
gibt ja auch immer wieder bedenken zu
sicherheitslücken jetzt glaube ich
einerseits die größte sicherheitslücke
im zusammenhang mit der app ist die
abwesenheit eines corona wann app
gesetzes ich habe ja schon erklärt warum
aber es gibt auch andere it sicherheits
lücken zum beispiel die sich auf
bluetooth der zugrundeliegenden
technologie beziehen
aber da muss man zum beispiel als
bundesregierung dafür sorgen dass das
zuständige amt das bsi auch
gerätespezifische
sicherheitsinformationen den nutzerinnen
und nutzern zur verfügung stellt dass
ich also weiß je nachdem welches iphone
oder google gerät oder welches telefon
überhaupt ich habe dass ich darf da für
spezifische informationen bekommen auf
deren basis sich entscheiden kann gehe
ich die eventuell vorhandenen kleineren
it sicherheitsrisiken ein oder ist für
mich der mehrwert wichtiger dass ich
vielleicht als risikopersonen vor einer
infektion frühzeitig geschützt werden
und auch andere schützen kann
danke für die einschätzung und einen
guten abend guten abend das gespräch mit
anke domscheit berg haben wir vorab
geführt diese corona app ist sozusagen
die hightech waffe es ist aber auch
interessant und finanziell enorm wichtig
wie anti corona maßnahmen in alltag und
der basis wird ganz praktisch seit die
grenzen in europa wieder aufgehen gibt
es dort natürlich gefällt
zwischen den corona strategien hoteliers
und wirte in bayern zum beispiel
protestieren dagegen dass sie die
strengeren maßnahmen ihres
ministerpräsidenten hart zu spüren
bekommen im wettbewerb wird österreich
wo es mittlerweile ein bisschen lässiger
zugeht berichtet claudia vogel
es läuft gut in murnau auf den ersten
blick die gemeinde in oberbayern ist am
wochenende gut besucht doch meistens
sind es tagesausflügler die hierfür
anstehen und abends wieder im eigenen
bett schlafen im fremdenverkehrsamt
werden ferienwohnungen für den sommer
bereits stark nachgefragt ganz anders
sieht es bei hotelbuchungen aus die
hotels können leider momentan noch nicht
ihre vollen leistungen anbieten
aufgrund der beschränkungen allen voran
dem wellnessbereich der kann nicht
geöffnet werden
und das sind natürlich schon massive
beschränkungen und bringt ein
wettbewerbs-nachteil noch gibt es in
bayern die strengsten auflagen zum
schutz vor dem virus auch im hotel
abstand halten mundschutz pflicht noch
bleibt der pool drinnen geschlossen auch
im alpenhof in murnau christian bär
bereite der strenge bayerische weg große
probleme gäste haben storniert gebucht
wird nur noch kurzfristig die
hotelzimmer waren seit ende mai nur zu
30 prozent ausgelastet die folge
67 mitarbeiter sind noch immer in
kurzarbeit
zuerst hat er versprochen machen sie
urlaub in bayern das hat uns gefreut
jetzt schickte alle aus bayern weg weil
wir die wellnessbereiche nicht öffnen
dürfen wir haben nur tagestourismus und
keine nächtigungen in den großen hotels
ganz anders eine knappe auto stunde
entfernt in österreich in seefeld in
tirol in dem bundesland das mit einem
corona hotspot in ischgl von sich reden
machte hier fallen in allen hotels
spätestens beim einchecken die masken
maximale luxus bei minimalen auflagen
sechs quadratmeter platz für jeden gast
im schwimmbecken drinnen wie draußen der
innenpool die ruheräume und die saunen
sind selbstverständlich geöffnet
auch hier gibt es an hygiene konzept
doch von auflagen rede die hotelchefin
ungern
der gast will es nicht mehr wissen der
hat genug mit internationalen künstlern
belebt sie das geschäft das hotel ist
ausgebucht
es gibt neue paradigmen aber man kann
aus allem das beste machen
urlauber haben die wahl wo sie sich
erholen wollen neue herausforderungen
auch für die gesundheitsämter in den
urlaubsregionen bieten garmisch
partenkirchen
es ist anders als in der phase des lok
ganz wo letztendlich ja die fallzahlen
im landkreis klar überschaubar war und
das wird sich perspektivisch wieder
erinnern
durch die aufhebung der reisewarnung für
fast alle eu-staaten wird es nun immer
schwieriger infektionswege nachzuweisen
urlaub mit einschränkungen in bayern
besteht die politik auf schutzmaßnahmen
vor einer zweiten infektionswelle für
die hotelbranche allerdings ist das ein
wirtschaftliches desaster nachrichten
vom grunde lag auf knapp drei wochen
nach dem tod von george freud in
minneapolis ist in den usa erneut ein
afroamerikaner von der polizei getötet
worden im us bundesstaat georgia in
atlanta war der 27 jährige vor einem
schnellrestaurant im auto eingeschlafen
polizisten kontrollierten den
alkoholisierten mann der sich seiner
festnahme widersetzte und dabei einem
beamten einen elektroschocker entwendete
als er diesen auf die polizisten
richtete wurde er von einem von ihnen
angeschossen und starb später im
krankenhaus
daraufhin kam es in atlanta zu neuen
protesten
demonstranten zündeten das
schnellrestaurant an
bei der explosion eines tanklastwagens
im osten chinas sind mindestens 19
menschen ums leben gekommen
170 wurden verletzt hunderte helfer sind
im einsatz
die wucht der explosion brachte
wohnhäuser und fabrikgebäude zum
einsturz mehrere fahrzeuge gerieten in
brand
der lkw hatte flüssiggas transportiert
die unglücksursache ist noch nicht
geklärt
die bundesregierung plant ein
millionenschweres hilfsprogramm um in
der korona krise ausbildungsplätze zu
sichern
unternehmen die ihre lehrstellen zahl
halten sollen mit 2000 euro unterstützt
werden die die zahl sogar erhöhen
erhalten 3000 euro weitere vorteile soll
es geben wenn kurzarbeit für azubis
vermieden wird die kosten des programms
werden auf insgesamt 500 millionen euro
geschätzt
unser ost asien korrespondent ulf röller
schickt uns eine bemerkenswerte
erfolgsgeschichte zum kampf gegen kobe
19 aus japan
ausgerechnet japan ein land mit
überbevölkerten millionenstädten mit
einer überalterten bevölkerung und einen
ziemlichen fehlstart in die pandemie
bekämpfung das sah es so aus als ob die
regierung das thema klein redete um
olympische sommerspiele in tokio nicht
zu gefährden
aber dann kam etwas ganz anderes ein
erfolgsmodell das zum vorbild taugen
könnte für den nächsten solchen fall
vielleicht auch bei uns wenn die skyline
von tokio roth erleuchtet sind die
bürger der stadt alarmiert das virus
breitet sich dann aus
doch in diesen tagen erstrahlt die
regenbogenbrücke in bunten farben kein
chor oder allah mehr für die 38
millionen metropole tokio us bürger
werden aber nicht übermütig modul ich
vermeide orte mit vielen menschen
deshalb habe ich keine angst aber das
virus verschwendet nicht schnell
bisher ist japan gut durch die korona
krise gekommen das liegt auch an der
disziplin der bevölkerung die gewohnt
ist masken zu tragen
nun sollen ab nächster woche weitere
beschränkungen fallen vor allem für bars
restaurants und den tourismus
also unsere corona maßnahmen beinhalten
diesen gesichtsschutz alle
reisebegleiter tragen plastikhandschuhe
und außerdem werden die hände
desinfiziert ab nächster woche soll es
wieder stadtrundfahrten geben der
ernstfall wird jetzt erst einmal geprobt
hatte busreisen ist ein sehr typisches
japanisches unternehmen das ganze land
bereitet sich auf die normalität vor das
virus hat den alltag von tokio aber auf
dauer verändert man kann sagen dass das
corona virus so ähnlich wie eine
katastrophe ist bis die ausbreitung
völlig gestoppt ist wird es noch lange
dauern
ganz japan schaut bei der bekämpfung des
virus auf professor titan der virologe
hat die korona strategie für die
japanische regierung entwickelt seine
these kann er mit vielen daten
untermauern
viele personen stecken niemanden an aber
einige wenige stecken besonders viele an
täglich koordiniert er mit seinem team
die krisenstrategie es geht dabei nicht
so sehr darum alle infizierten zu finden
sondern eben die sogenannten super
spread also die menschen die viele
anstecken und es geht darum die
infektions orte sogenannte cluster
ausfindig zu machen
durch intensive suchen konnten wir diese
cluster nachweisen und dann die
infektionsketten gezielt aus dem schier
vor allem menschenansammlungen drinnen
sind problematisch fitnessstudios bars
restaurants dürfen nun wieder bis
mitternacht aufmachen
professor ausschied an die wand zur
vorsicht wenn man nun alles wieder so
macht wie vor der korona krise kommt es
sofort zu einem gewaltigen ausbruch
das ist unbestritten nicht weggehen in
zeiten von corona der partner ist eine
puppe die lösung von einigen findigen
restaurants in tokio
zumindest steckt man sich da nicht an
nachricht nun vom sport und mehr in der
fußball bundesliga haben sich schalke 04
und bayer leverkusen 1 zu 1
unentschieden getrennt schalke nach 13
spielen in folge ohne sieg auf platz
neun der tabelle leverkusen verbessert
sich auf tabellenplatz vier und zuvor
hatte mainz 05 0 zu 1 gegen fc augsburg
verloren
augsburg durch den auswärtssieg auf
platz 13 der tabelle mainz bleibt auf 15
die deutsche tischtennis meisterschaft
hat zum ersten mal der erste fc
saarbrücken gewonnen
die mannschaft um nationalspieler
patrick franziska siegte im finale 3 1
gegen titelverteidiger ochsenhausen aus
baden württemberg wegen corona wurden
die spiele in frankfurt am main
ohne zuschauer ausgetragen seitenwechsel
gab es nicht es wurde viel desinfiziert
und ordentlich
in vielen regionen deutschlands haben
heftige sommergewitter auch heute
schäden verursacht starkregen führte zum
schlamm und wassermassen auf den straßen
es kam zu zahlreichen
verkehrsbehinderungen
vielerorts versuchte die feuerwehr mit
sandsäcken die überschwemmungen
einzudämmen
bei garmisch partenkirchen musste die
bergwacht 61 wanderer ins tal fliegen
wegen beschädigter brücken und
umgestürzter bäume waren die wanderwege
und passt hier waren vor den toren
moskaus ist die neue hauptkirche des
russischen militärs eingeweiht worden
die eröffnung der kirche des sieges ist
einer der höhepunkte der feiern in
russland zum 75 jahrestag des endes des
zweiten weltkrieges hunderte soldaten
nahmen an dem russisch orthodoxen
gottesdienst zur einweihung teil ebenso
wie die militärführung und verteidigungs
minister schoigu
die militärkirche ist das drittgrößte
gotteshaus russlands guter ruf schöne
sache kann aber eine schwere bürde sein
kommt ja immer aus der vergangenheit und
geht in der gegenwart schnell verloren
berlin erlebt dass gerade mit seinem ruf
als metropole der bildenden kunst
dieser ruf ist schwer zu halten wenn
namhafte künstler innen abziehen wenn
eine der erfolgreichsten und
aufregendsten deutschen künstlerinnen
ein letztes mal ein riesenberg erstellt
für ausstellungshallen im hamburger
bahnhof wie es so bald nicht mehr geben
wird
die abgerissen werden für profitableres
katharina grosse hat noch einmal
geschaffen wird gesehen und dann gehen
stephan merseburger berichtet über ein
fanal
es ist ein farbrausch ein explosives
gemisch greller und dunkle töne ein werk
das zunächst heiterkeit versprüht dann
aber auch etwas bedrohliches hat ist das
ein abgestürztes raumschiff eine
besonders schroffe bergwelt oder ein
geborstener eisberg auf solche fragen
gibt die künstlerin katharina grosse
keine antwort sie ist ein international
gefeierter star
gefragt von den wichtigen museen
weltweit jetzt hat sie im hamburger
bahnhof in berlin ihr bislang größtes
riesen gemälde gefertigt ich habe keine
angst vor dem gefühl dass mir alles zur
verfügung steht
sie malt in schutzkleidung mit
sprühpistole monate hat sie an dem
kunstwerk gearbeitet
es ist noch bis mitte januar zu sehen
dann verschwindet es wieder kunst für
die vergänglichkeit
also es gibt eine große schönheit in der
verschwendung und diese schönheit gelebt
dann aber weiter gerade weil es ein
ereignis ist und weil das ereignis in
der gegenwart erloschen ist
einmal und dann nie wieder das begehbare
werk ufert nach draußen aus und bringt
asphaltierte wege zum leuchten
selbstverständlich macht große auch vor
den regalen sinnbild für die krise
zeitgenössischer kunst in berlin nicht
halt sie sollen nächstes jahr abgerissen
werden und durch lukrative neubauten
ersetzt werden
das grundstück hat der bund 2007 an
privatinvestoren verkauft noch sind in
den regalen leihgaben der sammlung flick
zu sehen allesamt hochkarätig
lithographien von bruce nauman zb oder
fotografien von thomas struth der mit
zehn zieht sie ab nach zürich weil die
hallen zerstört werden es wird eine
große lücke reißen wenn die werke
abziehen
wir behalten die schenkungen wir müssen
mit unseren eigenen beständen arbeiten
katharina grosse lebt und arbeitet auch
in berlin
gern doch das kommerz zeitgenössische
kunst verdrängt sieht sie mit sorge dass
schwäche den kunststandort auch deshalb
hat sie die rieck allen bemalt das ist
letztlich ein ganz tolle möglichkeit neu
zu verhandeln
die muss ergriffen werden oder darf
ergriffen werden was dann dabei
herauskommt weiß ich nicht aber auf
jeden fall würde ich unbedingt dafür
plädieren dass wir diesen
internationalen standort ausbauen wir
sind für die bildende kunst wenn das
aber schief läuft will keiner schuld
sein
ich wusste dass wir sind es nicht
gewesen heißt die ausstellung das passt
wir sind wir haben in den sonntag
sendungen die schöne sitte ihnen und den
kollegin marietta und heinz schon mal
kurz zu zeigen was nächste woche ansteht
soweit man das erkennen kann jörg bild
macht es heute
[Musik]
vor dem oberlandesgericht frankfurt am
main wird am dienstag der prozess gegen
den mutmaßlichen mörder des kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke
beginnen
angeklagt sind der hauptverdächtige
stephanie und dessen mutmaßlicher
unterstützer marcus h bis ende oktober
sind 32 verhandlungstage vorgesehen
die kultusminister der länder werden am
donnerstag auf ihrer virtuellen
konferenz über das kommende schuljahr
und den umgang mit dem corona virus
beraten
nach dem willen von bildungsministerin
hubrich sollen alle altersstufen nach
den sommerferien zum normalen
regelbetrieb zurückkehren
am freitag werden die staats und
regierungschefs der eu bei einer
video-konferenz über den wiederaufbau
von der eu kommission beraten
das ende mai vorgelegte 750 milliarden
euro schwere paket stößt bei einigen
ländern auf großen widerstand
die afg wird am samstag in halle zu
einem sogenannten kleinen parteitag
zusammenkommen
das wird das erste persönliche
aufeinandertreffen der zerstrittenen
lager innerhalb der afg seien seit dem
parteiausschluss des brandenburgischen
landesvorsitzenden kalbitz
und die wetteraussichten für die neue
woche sind zweigeteilt im süden
deutschlands regnerisch im norden sonnig
und trocken
dort und im osten gibt es auch morgen
sonne sonst entwickeln sich gewitter mit
ergiebigen regen vor allem im süden mit
unwettergefahr
bei 15 bis 26 grad und in den nächsten
tagen bleibt es im nordosten trocken mit
viel sonne in der mitte und im süden
regnet es oft zum teil mit gewittern die
temperaturen erreichen 16 bis 28 grad
wir wünschen ihnen einen schönen abend
und eine gute zeit bis bald in kundu
last fall bis morgen und bis morgen
[Musik]